now right now at four our first look at
the 16 year old student accused of
strangling beating and sexually
assaulting his teacher according to an
arrest report from metro the team
claimed he quote didn't like teachers
and was getting revenge thank you for
joining us at four i'm kirsten joyce and
i'm christian casadas 16 year old
jonathan martinez garcia appeared in
court today and he faces 15 felony
charges according to that report
obtained by the 8 news now i-team garcia
is an 11th grader at el dorado high
school police say he went to the
teacher's classroom last thursday to
discuss missing assignments before
attacking the young woman garcia is
being processed as an adult but it was
determined today he'll need to be
evaluated by at least two doctors to
determine his competency
the person has to be competent in order
for us to proceed against him but that's
not stopping us from continuing to
proceed
in a course of achieving justice for
this victim
right now garcia is being held on a
500-thousand dollar bail now you can
find the full arrest report on our
website 8newsnow.com